et le ton
[Musique]
elle ne correspond peut-être pas à
l'idée qu'on se fait de la sibérie une
jeune femme branchée
toujours élégante femme quand il fait
moins 30 degrés ceignac austin a fait
dans la mode et l'auto promotion puis
des indes accros des réseaux sociaux
elle est une influence assumée qui ne
passent jamais inaperçus comme nous
l'avons accompagné au restaurant à ses
fils ont immédiatement reconnu la suite
religieusement sur instagram depuis le
tout début de la pandémie elle qui nous
a ouvert les yeux dit christina alors
qu'on disait encore aux russes de ne pas
s'en faire avec le corps enseignant
kostine à a été un des tout premiers cas
connus de kovy darcos qu'au début du
mois d'avril 2020 a fermé sous clef dans
une chambre d'hôpital au tac aux
tourelles à documenter son expérience en
commençant par l'état lamentable des
soins de santé
il saigne a continué de raconter sans
filtre ne manque de personnel l'absence
cruelle d'équipement des thermomètres au
ventilateur alors que l'état de santé de
sa voisine de chambre
irina se détériorer en direct sous les
yeux de ses cinquante mille abonnés
jean stage
la mort drina fut un choc mais aussi un
point tournant dit xenia de son petit
lit de métal interpeller directement les
autorités des bulletins de nouvelles ces
appels ont été entendus par le
gouverneur réunion d'urgence
réorganisation des soins et formation du
personnel ont suivi en kenya est sorti
de l'hôpital mois plus tard des
centaines de ventilateurs avaient été
distribués dans les hôpitaux de la
région d'ica qu'ovide l'a profondément
changé de fashionista bénévoles la voici
en train d'inaugurer un nouvel appareil
à résonance magnétique que la
polyclinique attendait depuis des années
senna a aussi mis sur pied sa propre
fondation pour venir en aide à la
communauté éprouvés par la pandémie xing
a sauté sur l'igname est indispensable
du juli aille à colney va une infirmière
qui a attrapé la coved aux soins
intensifs une parfaite inconnue
xénia est venu libre et des vivres et
l'encourager elle a su influencer les
plus hauts fonctionnaires d'ioulia ici
c'est un exploit et multi votre buy-in
sa stratégie de gabarit à notre problème
bien qu'elle soit toujours devant la
caméra à ksenia se sert désormais
d'instagram pour rallier sa communauté
est pas auxerre aujourd'hui elle
distribue des jouets premier aux enfants
malades qui n'ont pas vu leurs parents
depuis des semaines en raison de la
collaboration et elle est
particulièrement fière de son plus
récent projet qu'elle partage avec des
artistes locaux
une murale géante d'une médecin m'a
qui nous avons pu voir juste avant
qu'elle soit installée sur la façade de
l'hôpital là où tout a commencé il ya un
an une image personnelle et à ceux qui
n'ont pas le droit de s'arrêter un
symbole de la force de l'image et des
réseaux sociaux
même là où on s'y attend
[Musique]